we've seen now that we can apply linear
transformations in different coordinate
systems the transformations that we've
been performing before have all been
with respect to the standard bases so in
the last video i said look in standard
coordinates if you have some vector x in
your domain and you apply some
transformation then let's say that a is
the transformation matrix with respect
to the standard domain or with respect
to the standard basis then you're just
going to have this mapping you take x
you multiply it by a you're going to get
the transformation of x now the last
video and a couple of videos before that
or actually the one right before that we
said well look you can do the same
mapping but just in an alternate
coordinate system you could do it with
respect to some coordinate system or
in in some coordinate system with
respect to some basis b and that should
be the same thing it should just be a
different transformation matrix and in
the last video we actually figured out
what that different transformation
matrix is we had a change of basis so
let's say we had this basis right here
let me actually copy and paste
everything
so that we understand what we did so
this was the example let me copy it
let me paste it up here put
all of our takeaways from the last video
up here let me paste it right here
so the last video we said okay this is
my basis right there
and then we said let me copy and paste
let me copy and paste
that was my alternate basis
and then i have my
change of basis matrix and it's inverse
those will be useful to deal with so let
me copy and paste that
okay copy
and then i'm going to paste it
edit
paste
maybe it'll maybe i'll just write it
over there
not maybe the best order maybe i should
have written that first but i think we
get the idea and then we want to figure
out we want to write what our
transformation matrix is with respect to
the standard basis and i wrote that
i wrote that right over here
this was all from the last problem if
you're wondering where i got all this
stuff
let me copy
and then paste that
edit paste
so i'll paste that and then the whole
point of the last video is we figured
out what the transformation matrix is
with respect to this basis
with respect to this basis right here so
d
which was the big takeaway from the last
video
was equal to this right here
let me copy and paste
that copy and paste and though now we
have all of our takeaways in one place
edit
paste what i want to do in this video is
verify
is to verify that d actually works
that d actually works that i could start
with some vector x
that i can let me write it up here
let's say we let's take some example
vector so we can this transformation its
entire domain is r2 so let's start with
some vector x
let's say that x
is equal to
i don't know let's say it's equal to
minus 1.
now we could just apply the
transformation in the traditional way
and get the transformation of x so let's
just do that
the transformation of x is just this
matrix times x
and so what is that going to equal let
me see maybe i can just do it right here
in this corner to save space so it's
going to be this matrix times x so this
first term right here is going to be 3
times 1
plus
minus 2 times minus 1 or plus 2 right
minus 2 times -1 is just 2. so it's
going to be 3 plus 2 so it's going to be
equal to five and then the second term
right here is going to be two times one
plus minus two times minus one well
that's just positive two so it's going
to be two plus two so that is four
so that's just the transformation of x
now what is
what is this vector x
represented
in coordinates or i guess we could say
to this alternate basis coordinates
so what is that vector x represented in
coordinates with respect to this basis
right here well you saw before i wrote
them out here maybe it'll be useful to
do it right here
the chord and i'll copy this little
actually let me copy both of these these
will both be useful
edit copy as you can see if you want to
go from x to the
to the x in an alternate basis or the
alternate coordinate representations of
x you essentially multiply x times c
inverse but that's why i'm copying and
pasting it
let me copy and then let me put it up
here so that we can apply these so then
paste it
right there
so if we want to go
if we want to go from
if we want to go from x to the b
coordinates of x i take my x and i
multiply it times c inverse c inverse is
this thing right here so if i take x and
i multiply it times c inverse
and i multiply times t inverse i'll get
this version of x so let's do that maybe
i could so this times that let me just
put the minus one third out front
it's going to be equal to minus one
third
times
let's see if we can do this one in our
head as well
so it's going to be one times one
plus
minus 2 times minus 1 which is just
positive 2. so it's going to be 1
plus 2 so it's going to be equal to 3
and then it's minus 2 times 1 which is
minus 2
plus 1 times -1 which is just minus one
so it's minus two minus one it's minus
three so if we have minus one third
times this
the b coordinate representation of our
vector x
is going to be
is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to minus 1
and then
just like that which is actually
interesting for this example it just
kind of swapped the the first entry in
the second entry
now let's see what happens when we apply
d to x
so if we apply d to x right d should be
our transformation matrix if we're
dealing in the b coordinates so let's
see what happens
so if we apply d to x let me scroll over
a little bit
let me scroll over a little bit just so
we get a little bit more real estate so
if we apply d to x what do we get and so
this what this is going to be this is
going to be
the transformation or this should be the
transformation of x
in b coordinates so what is this going
to be equal to
what is this going to be equal to we
have to multiply this times d
so it's going to be minus 1 times minus
1 which is 1 plus 0 times 1. so it's
just minus 1 times minus 1 which is 1.
and then we're going to get 0 times
minus 1 plus 2 times 1. so 2 times 1 is
just 2.
2 times 1 is just 2.
now for everything to work together and
assuming i haven't made any careless
mistakes
this thing
this vector right here should be the
same as this vector if i change my basis
so if i go from the standard basis to
the basis b when you go in that
direction you just multiply this guy
times c
inverse so you and i'm just using this
formula right here if i'm in the
standard basis i multiply by c inverse
i'm going to get the b basis so let's
see what i get so this guy i'm going to
multiply him times c inverse let me do
it up here just to
get some extra space let me do it right
here so i'm going to multiply
the vector 5 4 i'm going to multiply
that by c inverse we're going to have
minus 1 3
times
1 minus 2
minus 2
just like that so this is going to be
equal to i'll just write the minus 1 3
out front and we have 1 times 5 which is
5 let me just write this right 5
plus minus two times four so five minus
eight
five minus eight
and then we have minus two times five
which is minus ten
minus ten and then we have one plus one
times four minus 2 times 5 which is
minus 10 plus 1 times 4 plus 4. so this
is equal to minus 1 3
times minus 3 and this is what this is
minus 6.
if you multiply the minus 1 3 times it
all the negatives cancel out and you get
one and two which is exactly what we
needed to get when you would take this
guy and you change its basis to basis b
or you change its coordinate system to
the coordinate system with respect to b
you multiply it by c inverse you get
that right there so this is
this literally is the b coordinate
representation of the transformation of
x we just did it by multiplying it by c
inverse which is exactly what we got
when we took the b coordinate version of
x the b coordinate version of x and we
applied that matrix that we found that
the the transformation matrix with
respect to the b coordinates when you
multiply it times this guy right here we
got the same answer so it didn't matter
whether we went this way around this
little cycle or we went this way we got
the same answer this isn't a proof but
it shows us that what we did in the last
video at least works for this case and i
literally did pick a random x year and
you can verify it if you like for other
things
now you should hopefully be reasonably
convinced that we can do this that you
know you can change your basis and find
a transformation matrix we've shown how
to do it but the obvious question is why
do you do it
why
why do you do it and someone actually
wrote a comment on the last video which
i think is actually it kind of captures
the art of why you do it someone if i'm
not looking at the comment right now but
if i remember correctly it said some
they said their linear algebra teacher
said that linear algebra is the art of
choosing the right basis let me write
that down the art
of choosing
choosing
the right basis
or
you could imagine the right coordinate
system and why is there a right
coordinate system maybe i'll put little
quotes inside the quotation what what
does it mean to have the right
coordinate system well if you look at
the original transformation matrix with
respect to the standard basis it's fine
it's got this two by two but if you
performed matrix operations with this
it's you know you got to do some you got
to do some math and if you had to
perform it over and over if you had to
perform it on a bunch of vectors it
might get a little bit you know it is
what it is but when you transfer your
bases when you go to a new basis when
you went to this basis right here all of
a sudden you find that the
transformation matrix is much simpler
it's a diagonal matrix when you multiply
a diagonal matrix times something you're
literally just taking scaling factors of
the first and second terms when you
multiply this guy times some vector we
did it here when you multiplied this
this guy
when you multiply this guy
times this vector you literally just
scaled the first term times -1 and you
scaled the second term by two so it's a
much simpler operation and you might say
hey but we have to do all of that work
of multiplying by c inverse to get there
and then once you get this answer you're
gonna have to multiply by c to go back
into standard coordinates you know
that's a lot more work than just what
you save here but imagine if you had to
apply d multiple times imagine if you
had to apply d times d times d times d
to x or and or you know let me see this
way imagine if you have to apply a times
a times a like you have to apply a 100
times to sum to some vector up here then
applying a 100 times to some vector it
would be much more computationally
intensive than applying d a hundred
times to this vector even though you had
a little bit of overhead from converting
in this direction and then converting
back so in a lot of problems especially
in computer science frankly or you know
some other applications you might be
doing you want to pick the right basis
that problems or at least the
computation for many problems get a lot
simpler if you pick the right
the right the right coordinate system